kollege philippe piatti philipp du
konntest ebene beobachten wie
tatsächlich auch bei dir die menschen
sich versammelt haben um in einen
luftschutzbunker zu gehen du hast deine
position verändert wo stehst du jetzt
ich bin hier gerade in den wohngebieten
von lemberg unterwegs mit einigen
passanten verletzt sich genauso wie
sprechen was ich hier mache ich habe
allerdings vor einigen minuten eine sehr
wichtige information aus dem büro des
bürgermeisters erhalten und zwar hat die
stadtverwaltung von lemberg in ganz
dringenden verdacht dass innerhalb der
stadt russische sabotage einheiten
kooperieren genau das hatte der
bürgermeister von lemberg gestern mir
auch im interview gesagt dass womöglich
sabotage einheiten bis nach lemberg
vordringen könnten um eventuell die
kritische infrastruktur zugreifen oder
terroranschläge zu verüben offenbar
scheinen sich da die hinweise zu
verdichten die luftschutzbunker haben
sich ehrlich fragt er schnell geleert
nachdem die menschen gemerkt haben dass
es vorerst keine luftangriffe gibt die
sind erst mal alle in die luft
schutzbunker gestürmt haben sich dort
etwas beruhigt etwas gefangen und sind
dann wieder raus jetzt müssen sie
erfahren dass die gefahr offenbar nicht
aus der luft kommt in lemberg sondern
von sabotage einheiten also ein
spezialeinheiten der russischen
streitkräfte die es bis nach lemberg
geschafft haben und hier natürlich
verdeckt operieren was bedeutet das
konkret welche gefahr droht jetzt
das ist eben das problem das kann man
hier nicht genau sagen wir wissen nicht
niemand weiß was russische sabotage
spezialeinheiten hier anrichten könnte
man versuchen das stromnetz lahm zu
legen und könnte natürlich auch
militärische stützpunkte hier angreifen
auch hier melden sich natürlich sehr
viele junge aber auch ältere männer bei
der armee und wollen an die front man
hier ist ein großer flughafen hier ist
ein bahnhof also es gibt hier genug
infrastruktur die man angreifen könnte
aber das ist eben das besondere an
diesen sabotage einhalten niemand weiß
was sie planen
präsident zelaya hatte vor wenigen
minuten sich an das ukrainische volk
gewandt findet das ist nicht weniger als
eine general
wir machen des ganzen landes die er dort
ausgerufen hat jeder bürger der kann
wird zu den waffen gerufen momentan
lemberg immer so etwas als ein sicherer
hafen im westen der ukraine aber diese
illusion hat sich heute zerschlagen
viele menschen machen sich von kiew aus
auf unterwegs und sind unterwegs in
richtung westen eine lange lange staus
in der hauptstadt aber sie werden nicht
nur nach länder kommen wenn sie auch
feststellen dass sie auch dort nicht
sicher sein können lemberg ganz nah an
der polnischen grenze das ziel wird dann
möglicherweise polen seien zunächst
einmal und damit die europäische union
lemberg erwartet einen ansturm an
flüchtlingen ich war hier den ganzen tag
schon mit menschen unterwegs die
versuchen wohnungen zu organisieren und
größere unterkünfte zu organisieren
lemberg ist immer noch verhältnismäßig
sicher verglichen mit dem rest des
landes das die ganzen lange schlangen
die ganzen stars die wir sehen und
menschen die versuchen aus vier
rauszukommen davon werden einige heute
abend heute nacht wahrscheinlich in
lemberg ankommen und dann werden wir
sehen ob die stadt wirklich darauf
vorbereitet